welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and it's time to
celebrate thor's day with a bang as
we're gonna be breaking down the ending
of thor love and thunder kids get to pop
corner let me tell you the story of the
space viking the new marvel movie has a
lot to unpack from it and its final few
scenes set up some major things for the
future i am the god of spoilers giving
you one warning before we get into it so
if you haven't checked it out then check
out now if you enjoy the video then we'd
love to see you come back to us like
mania so make sure you subscribe because
fate worlds it's so with that out of the
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the ending of thor live
and thunder so the film ends with both
jane and gore dying with a lot of
entrusting thor to look after his
daughter love love is played by chris
hemsworth's real-life daughter and his
son also makes an appearance as a
younger version of odensen thematically
the movie is very much about love loss
and also finding love beyond the loss
when the heart starts to heal this is
reflected in love who thor ends up
taking care of at the end of the film he
wields malnia while she wields
stormbreaker and he raises her as his
own kid making breakfast for her and
getting her ready for a big battle
however it's very bittersweet as jane
isn't there and the first major thing i
want to talk about is her death and the
post-credits scene
jane in that we watch her reach the
gates of valhalla and here she's greeted
by none other than heimdall who of
course was killed at the beginning of
infinity war now the story of jane is
heavily based on the mighty thor run and
if you go off that there's actually a
big chance that she's gonna come back in
both the comics in film we pick up with
jane as a cancer patient who's going
through chemotherapy the outlook is very
bleak and it's through this that she's
led into becoming the mighty thor now in
the source material jane received her
diagnosis whilst thor was off fighting
gore in a book that we'll talk about in
just a bit she underwent treatment and
whilst this was going on though ended up
becoming unworthy due to a fight with
nick fury moliere was left on the moon
and from here it reached out to jane who
then traveled to it with the help of
heimdall upon reaching it she gained the
power of the god which took her from an
ordinary woman into the mighty version
that we meet in the film now in the
movie we discover that jane and thor
spent a lot of time together between the
events of the dark world and also thor
ragnarok they were great in love she'd
go do the signs he'd go fight the
battles and they lived happily together
for some time however the pair grew
apart due to their individual
insecurities and she ended up breaking
up with him by leaving a note no i don't
have a phone but you could have sent her
the electronic letter it's called an
email now this plays out in a really
great sequence of events and an
important part of this montage is that
we learned thor told malnier to protect
jane at all costs simmered how odin
created a sigil upon uttering the
worthiness spell in the first film doing
this also binds the hammer to her which
ends up becoming the reason that the
pair are linked in the film we catch up
with jane and she's going through
chemotherapy and we see a patient
reading her book the foster theory which
we heard being discussed all the way
back in the first thor movie now this
involved the idea that one could travel
through gateways in space and we get a
little reference to the wormhole
explanation from event horizon and
interstellar eric selve can't cure her
cancer there's a visit from darcy and
lady siff also helps to set up the rules
that one must die in battle in order to
get into valhalla there's also nods to
sif's costume in the comics as well as
the thunderstrike thor one that he wore
in the 90s jane ventures out a new
asgard which is overseen by king
valkyrie and the pieces of the hammer
are on display there there's also a play
with matt damon as lucky once more sam
neil is odin and luke hemsworth as
though this time though they're joined
by melissa mccarthy who's now playing
heller now after jane gets ammonia she
ends up gaining the power of thor but
this also worsens her cancer we get the
reason for this discussed in much
greater detail and it basically boils
down to this because thor is a god the
cells in his body are strengthened and
his immune system is extremely powerful
this makes his body capable of wiping
out all toxins and diseases within
seconds and this ends up backfiring on
jane because the chemotherapy drugs
attack cells a god's body would see this
as a threat and instantly wipe out the
treatment in the blood however because
all the cells within a god's body are
hardened the tumor itself also becomes
more resilient and this kills jane
faster than it would have had she not
become thor now throughout the movie she
teams up with odinson and together they
set out on a quest to stop gaw the god
butcher the constant transformations end
up taking a toll on her body and by the
end of the film she dies in his arms
throughout the movie there's jokes about
how she can't nail down a catchphrase
and she whispers it into his ear at the
end thor says it's perfect and though we
don't hear what it is i'd like to think
it's something really stupid like every
rose has its thor now
this arc is similar to comics and in
those she transformed one last time in
order to stop mangog from destroying
asgard here it's a lot simpler but we
can actually see where things will go in
the comics to roughly plot out how
she'll return now she comes across
heimdall at the gates of valhalla and
because she died in battle she'll be
able to enter it in the comics something
similar happened but thor ended up
calling her consciousness back and he
channeled the god tempest through the
broken monier which ended up
resurrecting her jane vowed not to waste
the second chance she'd been given and
she turned away from being the mighty
thor in order to focus on her
chemotherapy she ended up beating the
disease and eventually jane became a
valkyrie which is how i think she'll
return in the mcu i can see there being
a bit of a break before her next
appearance but i do think that the
post-credits scene at valhalla teases
that they are following the same story i
think that she will return to the land
of the living because fate wills it so
and that she and thor will end up
raising love together instilling in her
the best qualities that they both have
now one thing that thor has is fantastic
hair i used to have it too but age
watching movies the stress of getting
comments from chumps calling me a loser
it got the better of me that's why i
decided to team up with keeps the online
clinically proven treatment that helps
men to keep their hair now did you know
that one in two men experience some form
of hair loss by the time they're 35 can
be a real bummer on your self-esteem but
keeps off as research-based treatment to
not only stop hair loss but it also
helps with hair growth the treatments
are all doctor recommended and delivered
straight to your door at about half the
cost of most pharmacies on top of this
you also get 24 7 support like
stormbreaker you can reach out anytime
and keeps will be there for you with
their specialists each treatment plan
comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging so you can see your doctor
anytime like heimdall whether you want
to prevent hair loss stimulate hair
growth or just take better care of your
hair then keeps has you covered in
addition to the clinically proven
treatments keeps has an award-winning
all-natural thickening shampoo and
conditioner system it's everything your
hair needs delivered straight to your
home you can easily subscribe to keeps
and you get refill reminders so you
don't run out of the products you need
to take care of your hair hair loss
stops with keeps and you can get 50 off
your first order by going to keeps.com
heavy spoilers or by just clicking the
link in the description below that's
keeps.com heavyspoilers to help support
the channel and help support your hair
with this great deal cheers
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves now gore is an incredible
villain in the film and christian pale
really brings his all as the god butcher
who's here to murder everyone along with
paul allen his arc in the movie is
heavily based on the thor god of thunder
run in which he made his debut in that
book we got a really in-depth look at
his psyche and discovered that he came
from a barren wasteland where he had to
fight to survive every single day
because the people of the planet had so
little they became devoutly religious
and they cry out of the gods every day
desperate for help if they survived they
believed that the gods had blessed them
with whatever scrap of food or water
they came across and they became highly
superstitious gore's mother was killed
in front of him when he was very young
and though he escaped her final words
instilled in him the feeling that he
should always lurk to higher powers for
help however after the death of his wife
and child he started to curse the gods
and fearing retribution for having a
blasphemer amongst them his tribe cast
him out to die in the crew wasteland at
this point he came across two gods
jeweling that had crash landed on the
planet and one carried with them the
necro sword a powerful blade that in the
comics is synonymous with the god null
here due to bloody sony
in sony marvel didn't include him likely
because sony would make them sign a
contract where they acknowledge morbius
exists and that he's gonna be in the
thunderbolts or something anyway the
golden god wins but badly beaten he
cried out to go for help gore realized
that the gods he'd worshipped were weak
and self-centered and he vowed to kill
them all for not liking the video and
subscribing now the prologue for the
film changes things up and in that we
join gore and his daughter who are left
in the sweltering ruins of their home
planet she ends up dying and he wanders
the wasteland until he comes across a
lush oasis which is occupied by the god
that he'd been praying to similar to the
comics he just defeated the wielder of
the necro sword and he's there basking
in the glory while score is at death's
score
now goal pleads to him to deliver the
divine reward that was promised to his
followers but the god mocks him which
leads to the necro sword reaching out to
gore before the god can kill him he
claims his first victim and it shows him
flashes of eternity he orders the words
oh god she will die and goes after each
one of them like they owed in money hey
odin money that's a good
you suck now the film also takes other
notable elements from the graphic novel
run as we get the story narrated to us
by korg he shows up telling the story at
several points and in the comics though
actually narrate the tale to one of the
youngsters on the planet he'd arrived
there to find there were no gods which
led him to discover that the ones who
ruled over it had been taken out by gore
but corg recounts the times that thor
fell in love he's now decided to cut
himself off from it and he just travels
with the guardians believing his only
purpose is to be a warrior that people
call upon star-lord shares some
similarities with him as he lost gamora
similar how thor loses jane but he
hammers home the idea that it's better
to have loved and lost than to never
have loved before after learning of gore
he sets her to his next target at new
asgard and thor comes across jane gore
ends of kidnapping the children of
asgard including heimdall's kid axel
which confirms the fan theory that
heimdall
thor and cows head out across the cosmos
to recruit an army of the gods there's a
nod to tom cruise's film cocktail and
they arrive at omnipotent city in the
comics this was an area that thor
traveled to as it housed the hall of the
lost a library that contained details
about every missing god it basically
created a road map for thor to try
score's butchering and here he came
across falagar the behemoth who he also
runs into in the movie the shot looks
exactly the same as how it does in the
comics but instead of being the hall of
the lost omnibuddin city is actually
housing a ceremony hosted by zeus lots
of cameos here including gods dragons
and celestials who of course appeared in
the tv spots it would be the perfect
place to have a gorgey
but zeus is very much showboating here
and he refuses to join the fight
he tells the crowd there's nothing to
fear but admits to thor that he's
terrified and he's a good example of why
you should never tweet your heroes thor
group analyzing him and he was his
childhood hero however this shatters his
view of the gods and he sort of reflects
scores questioning of the deities now
thor believes that zeus killed korg and
he ends up catching one of his lightning
bolts which he then launches back at him
seemingly killing him too i say
seemingly because as we learn in the
other post-credits scene the god is
actually alive and he's
because of this russell crowe will
likely be returning as the big bad for
the next film as he and pretty much
everyone now hates thor he talks about
how people used to worship gods without
even knowing whether they existed or not
and how times have changed they used to
pray for lightning and rain but now when
they look at the sky they want to see
superheroes zeus is angered by this and
he wants everyone to become god-fearing
once more so he'll no doubt rain terror
on all the worshippers that turn their
backs on him zeus is also joined by his
son hercules who we see is played by
brett goldstein you might recognize him
from ted lasso derek and also the pact
hercules has been a major part of marvel
comics for a while now and due to the
character being out of copyright they've
milked them more than a homelander scene
now having all the myths and legends
tied to the character made it easy to
flash out his backstory and in the
comics he's got the exact same origin
story this includes him being outcast
his 12 labors and everything they
covered in the disney movie that they're
now making into live action
yay another another one of them now in
the comics he's had several run-ins with
thor over the millennia and he once led
a crusade against his viking followers
the pair had somewhat of a rivalry in
the past however for the majority of
their time together they have been
allies hercules has been part of the
avengers and during the new labour's run
he stated that thor was one of his
mightiest friends
therefore i think he'll actually end up
working with the god of thunder and that
they'll end up fighting his father along
with love and potentially jane as a
valkyrie this has some basis in the
comics and zeus was put on trial shortly
after the events of secret invasion
this was carried out by his brother
pluto and though it was pretty much a
mock trial used purely to determine his
guilt they could adapt this into the
upcoming films as i said zeus was found
guilty and he was forced to drink from
the river latve revelato which turn him
into a child possibly signifying where
things can go in the future without
turning thor into a god butcher himself
i think this is why they did the fake
out in the film as it kind of defeats
the point of taking out gore if thor is
murdering gods himself anyway he ends up
taking the guards thunderbolt and they
set out on a journey to the shadow realm
in the comics gore had found a way to
travel through time there's lots of
timely whiny wibbly wobbly stuff and we
actually meet three versions of him one
from the past present and a much
elevation of the god who had been
fighting gore for 900 years in this
dystopian world gore had kidnapped
several of the young gods and he had
them working on a device known as the
god bomb which was capable of destroying
every single god throughout the timeline
the three thor's battled it out with
gore and all the guards preyed to thor
which granted him enough power to absorb
the bomb he was aided by gore's son who
turned against his father after
realizing that he had killed his mother
she had been brought back by gaul and
she patiently waited until the day he
killed all the gods so that they could
spend some time together like my wife
when i tell her we can go on holiday
once the mcu ends which is never
now she ended up calling him a guard
because he'd managed to become an
immortal fueled by his hate that decided
the fate of all the other gods realizing
he'd become the very thing he hated he
ended up killing her and he became the
god of hypocrisy gore was killed in the
comics but in the film he somewhat goes
on a redemptive arc in the film his plan
is to use the bifrost and this will help
him open a gateway to eternity in the
comics eternity is an entity that
actually embodies the entire marvel
universe and he's very much the universe
as much as the universe is him there's
also a statue room in the film that's
filled with the heads of the watcher
lady death aeon and the living tribunal
who's been popping up quite a lot
recently now in the movie getting to
eternity allows you to make a wish and
gauze gauzes presumably to kill all the
gods he ends up getting stormbreaker
after an incredible fight scene that
feels like one of the most visually
enthralling moments in the mcu valkyrie
is stabbed and jane is left really weak
due to the cancer one more
transformation is gonna be a one-way
trip for her and similar to comics she
has to later decide whether to sacrifice
herself in order to save thor after this
everyone returns to earth and thor tells
jane to rest up whilst he goes to fight
gore he then venges out to eternity and
has a battle with the villain at the
gates of it this is where the kids have
been taken and thor ends up empowering
them with his abilities thor and gore go
head to head with a former losing really
badly now at this point jane decides to
take on the mighty thor mantle once more
and she arrives to help out the necro
sword is destroyed but during this time
the doors of eternity open and gore goes
forward in this place sits eternity and
gore and thor have a bit of a back and
forth gore could wish for the gods to be
wiped out which would mean the end of
thor unless he chooses to spend his last
potential moments with jane who's also
dying too though tells him that what he
really wants is love and that he can
wish for his daughter to return gore
thinks that she'd be alone because he's
also dying but jane says that he won't
be gore makes this wish and both he and
jane die with the former telling him to
look after his child as the movie ends
cork says that he's now found love
himself with a guy named dwayne like
dwayne the rock
made a rock
sith helps to train the children of
asgard and thor is racing gauze today
they are very much the love and thunder
with stormbreaker and malnier also
representing this too that ends the
movie and we also get a big nod to the
mighty thor run as we get a statue of
jane that looks exactly like how it did
in the comics great way to close it all
out and a big heartfelt moment as we
watch this father and daughter well well
uncle and daughter duo set out on a new
path
[Music]
now as for my thoughts on the film i
think it was a really solid entry and
though i probably prefer ragnarok
overall this still had some really great
moments in it i think you can tell there
were some bits of it left on the cutting
room floor and had the movie even been
just 15 minutes longer i think that
would have fleshed out certain things
that i just have hang-ups on i love
christian bale in the film but i really
wish that we got more of him because
he's not in the movie as much as i think
he should have been the comics had gore
as a major antagonist throughout the
whole god of thunder run and here he's
not in it enough to completely knock it
out the park which i think he was very
close to doing the adventures with the
guardians as well feel slightly
underdeveloped and i wish we just got to
spend more time with them so we could
really feel their camaraderie i think
also the tone of the movie can be a bit
up and down at points and though some of
the jokes didn't fully land for me most
of them did which made it a good laugh
chris hemsworth just embodies the god of
thunder and natalie portman by far has
her best performance as jane fonda sorry
jody foster but moving on now there's
lots of neat easter eggs too such as the
space dolphins infinity cones several of
the gods and the aesthetic of the final
battle works really really well love the
black and white chrome feeling to the
entire thing and those last couple of
scenes really hit me in the feels just a
shame they had to cut some stuff down as
i think the emotional beats would have
hit even harder if they'd been left in
overall i'm wrestling back and forth
between giving this a seven or an eight
nothing that it probably falls more
towards the lower numbers just because
of the hang-ups i have still though i
don't think it's the worst thor movie
ever like a lot of reviewers are making
out and to me it just falls short of
ragnarok without feeling like it had
more room to breathe so yeah 7.5 out of
10 maybe but that could definitely pick
up on subsequent watches i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts and other
films very divisive so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are
running competition right now and giving
away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th of
july and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film if you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now say that to you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out upright and have
stranger things which will be linked on
screen right now we went over the big
finale just last week it's a great video
so definitely go check it out right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through this one i've been poor
i'll see you next time take care peace